it sometimes comes as a bit of a
surprise to discover that
certain movies have their own sequels or
prequels
but finding out they're part of a whole
trilogy
can be downright astounding from
underrated classics to straight to video
monstrosities
these are a few of those movies the
xxx series is all about explosions
fights
and tacky one-liners the first movie
cashed in on vin diesel's fast and
furious street cred
giving him the title role as one note
badass
xander xxx cage and although there's
plenty on offer here for action fans
the prefab script kinda lets the rest of
the movie down
xxx state of the union switch from
diesel to ice cube
might have seemed ill-advised but cube's
charisma and sense of wonder as criminal
mastermind turned secret agent
darius stone basically carries this
absurd example of popcorn cinema
and sure the talents of sam jackson and
willem dafoe are pretty much
wasted but so what nobody is going to
see a movie called triple x state of the
union for dramatic nuance
diesel then returned to the franchise
for the belated third installment
2017's xxx return of xander cage and the
results were
well they were more or less exactly what
you'd expect
directed by park chanwook oldboy first
stole the spotlight when it won the
grand prix at ken
introducing a whole lot of people to
korean cinema
and stunning audiences around the world
it also set
the gold standard for hallway fights and
featured the octopus eating scene of all
octopus eating scenes the movie also
inspired
a sadly inferior sequel that just
couldn't compare to the epic tragedy of
the original film
still if you want to explore the twisted
mind of park chan rook
even further then you're in luck because
old boy is
actually the second installment in the
director's so-called
vengeance trilogy this loosely thematic
saga began in 2002
with sympathy for mr vengeance the story
of a man seeking revenge for the death
of his daughter
then oldboy was released in 2003 the
story of a man who sets out to bring
down the people who imprisoned him for
15 years
park finished his trilogy with lady
vengeance the story of a woman who hunts
down the man who committed the crime for
which she was framed
obviously the trilogy revolves largely
around the concept of vengeance
and most notably the idea that getting
even with your enemies
never really solves your problems in
park's world
revenge is a messy bloody and murky
business
and even if the protagonists succeed in
finding vengeance
they're never much better off at the end
of these movies
and while each film explores this in
slightly different ways
the vengeance trilogy is still a
must-watch
series for fans of korean movies
gore-soaked cinema
and stories that aspire to the bloody
heights of shakespeare
coming off the back of his starring role
in sons of anarchy
taylor sheridan decided to write sicario
a brutal
screenplay about america's war on drugs
and the nightmarish
violence along the u.s mexican border
eventually the script picked up
an incredible cast as well as the nigh
on unbeatable pairing of director denis
villeneuve
and cinematographer roger deakins
inevitably when sicario hit theaters in
2015's
the critics were floored sheridan's next
project was the equally impressive
helmer high water
a modern-day western that follows two
west texas brothers as they rob banks in
one
economically desolate town after another
the script earned sheridan
an oscar nomination as well as one for
jeff bridges for his turn
as a surly texas ranger a year later
sheridan made his directorial debut with
wind river
a movie set in the snowy wilderness of
wyoming where a hunter and an fbi agent
attempt to solve the murder of a native
american woman
while there aren't any individual
characters linking these films together
sheridan has describes his films as a
frontier trilogy
talking with the associated press
sheridan said these movies are
an exploration of the modern american
frontier and how much has changed
and how much hasn't changed and the
consequences of assimilation that still
reverberate
today to that end sheridan's frontier
trilogy is
very much an examination of the secret
struggles
and brutal realities of living in the
rural us
a series about the forgotten people of
north america and
their desperate fight for survival
thanks to guillermo del toro's love for
all things weird and wonderful
the world has been gifted with some
truly incredible films
such as pan's labyrinth and the shape of
water
but before del toro was known as the
monster maestro
he struggled with a little creature
feature called mimic
del toro had a very specific creative
vision for the movie
but the studio wanted something
different and the resulting film is
well let's just say it's not one of the
director's best
still it has its moments and the premise
which involves
giant cockroaches impersonating human
beings is
at least pretty cool while mimic was
anything but a box office success it
must have had
that certain something because somebody
at dimension films
then decided it had franchise potential
mimic 2 was released direct to dvd in
2001
and played out like an ickier version of
beauty and the beast
the sequel followed an entomologist from
the first film who's being stalked by a
jealous humanoid insect that wants her
for um romantic purposes
interestingly the 2003 straight to video
follow-up mimic 3 sentinel
borrows the plot from rear window by
trapping its voyeuristic hero inside an
apartment
watching the world through his camera
his spying soon turns into sleuthing
however when he realizes there's
something strange happening across the
street
something that might just involve some
very hungry bugs
incredibly this unlikely trilogy capper
actually did pretty well with the few
critics who saw it
but then again who wouldn't want to
watch an alfred hitchcock movie with
killer cockroaches
it's a scientific fact that sharks are
the scariest animals
on the planet so it should come as no
surprise that open water thrilled
audiences at sundance
and subsequently scared up 54 million
dollars against a 500
000 production budget this aquatic indie
was directed by husband and wife
filmmakers chris kentis and laura lau
and followed an unlucky couple who
become stranded in the great barrier
reef
desperately trying to avoid becoming
sushi for the sharks
with such an impressive showing at the
box office it was only a matter of time
before a sequel came swimming along
but what's weird about open water 2
adrift
is that there's not a single shark in
sight that's right
no sharks originally titled just adrift
the movie wasn't supposed to have
anything to do with the movie by kentuc
and lau
but some executive came along and stuck
the name
open water on it the sequel follows a
bunch of genuine
idiots who jump off their yacht to go
swimming only to find they've forgotten
to lower the ladder first
stranded in the ocean our forgetful
heroes then have to desperately try to
get back on board
then came open water 3 cage dive
released
straight to video by lionsgate it
focuses on a group of americans who go
you guessed it go cage diving off the
coast of australia
this time the sharks actually show up
and soon enough these scuba divers are
little more than fish food still
although they at least got that part
right it goes without saying that open
water 3 isn't
exactly a masterpiece
source code director duncan jones spent
15 years working on his passion project
a sci-fi noir called
mute despite a myriad of personal and
professional problems that slowed him
down
jones soldiered on and finally finished
the movie which was released in 2018
mute follows a silent bartender in the
near future who embarks on a
blood-soaked quest to find his missing
girlfriend
based on the trailer you'd never guess
this was the second installment of a
trilogy
according to jones however mute takes
place in the same universe as
moon his critically acclaimed space
drama about a lonely astronaut on an
isolated moon base
jones calls his cinematic world the
mooniverse
and once promised a third film would
eventually come along to complete the
trilogy
in 2020 however jones revealed that he
was having trouble funding part 3 and
decided to make it a graphic novel
instead
with the hopes that it may eventually
become a movie in the future
maddie once upon a time in the future is
the story of two mercenary sisters on
the run
and was fully funded through a
kickstarter campaign
only time will tell if it gets the
cinematic treatment
a true classic of the 1980s the lost
boys is basically the goonies meets
dracula
directed by joel schumacher the film
follows two brothers who move to the
city of santa carla
otherwise known as the murder capital of
the world
naturally they have a difficult time
settling into their new home
especially since they're welcomed to the
neighborhood by a gang of motorcycle
riding vampires including a fanged up
kiefer sutherland and an undead bill on
a wholly different kind of adventure
excellent despite finding considerable
success at the box office the lost boys
laid dormant for over 20 years for a
brief moment there was talk of a sequel
titled the lost girls but
unfortunately that idea never came to
pass instead in 2008 we got
the lost boys the tribe a movie that
basically rehashed the plot of the first
film
it's all very familiar new kids move
into town face an evil vampire and when
things start getting freaky they turn to
a vampire hunter played by corey feldman
of course with such a stunningly
unoriginal plot
it should come as no surprise to find
that the tribe has an impressive
zero percent rating on rotten tomatoes
while the lost boys
the thirst has the same awful rating it
at least tries a little harder in the
plot department
released in 2010 the third movie in the
trilogy follows feldman as
aged vampire slayer edgar frogg who sets
out to stop a group of vampires from
using a demonic drug to transform
partygoers into undead monsters
of course the third entry can't hold a
crucifix to the original film
even with a more interesting premise so
maybe it's time for warner brothers to
stake this saga
in the heart written by quentin
tarantino and directed by robert
rodriguez
from dusk till dawn is a bonafide cult
classic released in 1996 the movie stars
tarantino and george clooney as criminal
brothers who escaped to mexico
after robbing and killing several people
they plan to spend the night hiding out
in a strip club before meeting their
contact at dawn
but what they don't know is that the bar
is staffed entirely by vampires
soon enough all hell breaks loose in a
full blown orgy of blood and violence
as well regarded as from dusk till dawn
is however
nobody seems to remember its two sequels
for one thing from dusk till dawn boasts
an amazing cast of 90s stars
but of its many lead actors only danny
trejo returned for 1999's from dusk till
dawn 2 texas blood money
instead of clooney and tarantino the
movie stars robert patrick and duane
whitaker
it also suffers for lacking the talents
of tarantino and rodriguez behind the
camera
and unsurprisingly ended up being
released directly to video
from dusk till dawn 3 the hangman's
daughter which got a direct
video release in 2000 is actually a
prequel set in the early 1900s
it features even less star power than
the second one but
hey at least danny trejo is still there
that
guy really needs to learn how to say no
to people
2017's call me by your name was a huge
success as far as independent movies go
gaining heaps of critical acclaim and
four
oscar nominations one of which it won
this
wistful romantic love story starred
armie hammer
and timothy chalamet in a whirlwind
summertime romance between two men with
something of an
age difference i'd kiss you if i could
still despite attracting a little
controversy in that regard
call me by your name was a resounding
triumph for director luca guadagnino
but what you might not know is that it's
actually the third installment in a
trilogy
guadagnino has often expressed his
interest in the desire that human beings
feel for one another
and he spent the better part of a decade
crafting a trilogy of narratively
unrelated films revolving around that
theme
the first was i am love in 2009 which
starred tilda swinton as the wife of a
wealthy industrialist who has a
passionate affair with a chef
then in 2015 came a bigger splash which
also starred swinton
this time as a rock star torn between
past and present lovers
even as her current boyfriend is tempted
by a younger woman
call me by her name is the only film in
guadagnino's desire trilogy not to
feature swinton
but it shares thematic elements and
picturesque italian settings with those
first two installments
whether that third movie marks the end
of guadagnino's aliens with desire
however is yet to be seen
william franken's 1971 movie the french
connection
is an absolute classic the gritty story
of a new york detective
popeye doyle in his attempt to thwart a
heroin smuggling operation
franken's picture influenced crime
cinema for decades to come
and is still considered a must see for
cinephiles today
but despite the french connections
enduring popularity
hardly anybody has seen french
connection 2
and most people don't even know there
was a third movie in the series too
gene hackman returned as popeye doyle
for french connection 2 with john
frankenheimer taking over directorial
duties
it follows popeye as he travels to
france in pursuit of alan charnier
the drug smuggler who escaped at the end
of the first film
fernando rey is the only other cast
member besides hackman to return for the
sequel
which also features a series of
harrowing scenes of addiction and
recovery as doyle is captured by
charnier
and injected with heroin as an
interrogation tactic
by the time charnier lets him go popeye
doyle is a full-blown
addict and must go cold turkey in a
french police station holding cell
it's not exactly a barrel of laughs the
third film to pick up the story is
called popeye doyle and stars ed o'neill
as the title character
the movie was made for television and
seemed designed as the launching point
for a television show but
the spin-off series never really
happened still
even if it was more of a tv pilot popeye
doyle was clearly
established as a further story following
the same character from the first two
films
so it certainly counts as the third
installment in the trilogy
[Music]
one of the all-time great monster movies
the creature from the black lagoon
introduced the world to the gill man the
scaliest member of the universal
monsters roster
and like his equally iconic cohorts old
gilly
inspired a franchise that would inspire
both fear
and pity in this prehistoric fiend the
whole concept of the gill man began when
producer william allen
attended a dinner party at orson welles
house there he met a cinematographer who
told the story of a reptilian monster
that lived in the amazon
and occasionally kidnapped native women
this bizarre anecdote inspired
a spark in allent who went on to make
that famous first film
which is about a troupe of explorers who
traveled to south america and encounter
an amphibious beast with a thing for
women in bathing suits
the movie was released in 3d a
revolutionary innovation at the time
and turned out to be an immediate hit
and before production had even finished
universal was already setting up the
next entry in a new series
the follow-up was titled revenge of the
creature and
in this film the gill man is captured
put on display
and tortured by scientists soon enough
however he escapes and our fishy friend
decides to go looking
for revenge things then get super weird
in the final film
the creature walks among us in this
entry the gill man is set on fire and
most of his skills are burned off then
after undergoing surgery the creature
comes out
looking incredibly human-like the rest
of the film follows the gill man
as he tries to adjust the human world
all the while
dreaming of his home beneath the water
it's
not great the 2010 sci-fi action film
skyline
is less a piece of cinema and more a
truly wild
over-the-top thrill ride it stars eric
balfour
and scotty thompson as jared and lynn a
married couple with a baby on the way
who attend a friend's birthday party as
aliens suddenly invade the los angeles
the film has a truly strange ending too
in which jared and elaine
are captured and taken aboard an alien
ship where jared's brain is extracted
from his body and
placed into a biomechanical alien body
you know
for reasons but jared's brain suddenly
glows red instead of blue like the other
alien drones
which apparently means he has retained
his memories and
personality the movie ends with the
alien jared protecting his still human
wife
and unborn child from the other aliens
incredibly things get
even stranger and beyond skyline a
follow-up flick in which elaine's
pregnancy is accelerated
as is the growth of the daughter to whom
she gives birth
along the way a resistance movement
against the aliens begins to come
together including other alien drones
who managed to maintain their inner
humanity just as
jared did the third movie in the trilogy
skylines
finds humanity and their half-human
allies finally managing to defeat the
aliens ten years later
under the leadership of jared and
elaine's fully grown ten-year-old
daughter
director liam o'donnell helmed all three
movies so there does appear to be
some kind of artistic vision at work
here no matter how little sense
it seems to make check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one